okay gut wir sind einer neuen folge und
alles so jetzt irgendwie falsch
geschnitten wird immer noch in der
letzten folge also frage von harry
selber master was ist euer lieblings
essen wo wir gerade beim thema sind
dünne mittlerweile damit anfangen so
gern weil wenn das wirklich jede pause
ist es das nicht mehr so toll
es stimmt wohl von daher mittlerweile
mag ich mag curry fleisch mit rides
curry sauce und zu viel ich extrem viel
theorie was mit reis 3 ist und alles das
ist voll geil ist das hammer das ist
richtig aber wenn du das sagst du da
sagst dann stimmt das
aber ich bin auch ich bin auch
currywurst die kammer currywurst auch
richtig geld vor allem erst mal ist man
ist man eigentlich relativ selten kann
es seien aber aber dies erst glich heute
noch currywurst also eine mutter holen
etwas von dem grill von bei uns niemand
meinem körper und ich habe eigentlich
gesagt ja vom currywurst mainz gesagt ja
kommen
lebst ein bisschen gesünder im
ferienhotel du kannst nicht gesund leben
unserer heutigen welt das funktioniert
nicht
na ja ihr seid ja so penner ihr habt ihr
schon ferien oder ich hab ja bitte
einmal die kommentare ein morgen ein
übermorgen übermorgen so richtig geile
für singer bei sonntag sonntag chef
versuche ich hab jetzt freitag noch so
geschrieben drei stunden lang
aber was immer ich wie kenia auf tauris
von goethe dort wo es normal auf tauris
das buch von goethe da verstehst du drei
antwort ich habe mir die komplette links
auf die pga durchgelesen gab es dann
nach halbwegs verstanden eigentlich eine
ganz gute klausur geschrieben
ich konnte einfach ich konnte nicht mehr
aufhören zu schreiben das eigentlich ein
ganz gutes zeichen
wir haben in der schule
wie heißt er heißt jetzt schneller nein
der kafka dkv das sind der reise ganz
kurze novellen er nicht nur wählen wer
ist das prosatext gehen über eine halbe
seite
ach sagt er zum beispiel ging zum
bahnhof damit dann kam ich mache das
jetzt einmal nach ich bin ich zum
bahnhof dann schaut er auf die turmuhr
wird relativ spät
er ging weiter aber er kannte sich in
der stadt nicht aus weil er fremd war
ging zu polizisten ging zu ihm hin sagte
so pipa pipapo du da kannst du den weg
sagen und dann der polizist jetzt kommt
sie zum knackpunkt kasus knaxus der sagt
was als ob ich dir was erzählen würde
und lachte ihn aus so fertig und jetzt
es ist schwierig von anspruchsvollen und
so war dann gibt es auch eine dritte
zeit ebene und zweite zeit geben du hast
ja oder nein habe ich nicht aber es ist
halt so dass er erst mal der so
gesellschaftskritik falls der der alm
ist der bild steht hat auch irgendwie so
gesellschaftlich zu über dem und dann
wird er dem ja nicht nichts erzählen
oder sowas
weil er in fremder ja und erheblich
ja er ist also irgend jemand irgendwas
anderes ist von irgendeinem der der
könig starben und möchte als letzter
gabe er möchte als letzten willen dem
dem schlecht am schlechten gestellten
aus einer ganzen königreich also wie ein
bettler oder so eine aufgabe teilen
der soll dann erfüllen irgendwie so ein
text irgendwo hinbringen und er muss
dann aus dem palast rausgehen irgendwie
aber er schafft das nicht weil er palast
immer größer wird und immer größer oder
endet nicht alter aber ich finde text
eigentlich extrem geil weil du dadurch
einfach seine chance dass der eagles
viel reininterpretieren der lehrer immer
eine interpretation vorgegeben also die
der das was der lehrer denkt was richtig
ist und wenn du irgendetwas anderes
sagen
komplett falsch richtig ja ja das ist
selbst wer das selbst also wir haben ja
noch so dingens klingt ja wie sie bei
uns so smartphone gesellschaft ist das
und selbst wenn wir dann während der
stunde so nach gucken was anderes
interpretiert haben und so was tragen
das denn genau so vor richtig perfekt
argumentiert und alles das ist falsch
türen und ideen die lehrer sagen also er
sagt auch immer ja wenn man irgendwas
richtig richtig argumentierten es mit
argumenten hinterlegt dann nämlich auch
andere sachen an da aber in der klausur
damals ja niemals nie das kann gar nicht
sein
auch in philosophie ganz schlimmes fach
philosophie ist allgemein sondern seine
lehrer für sich nicht einer dieser
geschrieben und das richtig beschissen
das gedicht sagt mal bitte was ihr dazu
hält linksseitige schmerzen bis zu den
nägeln was heißt es dass die arme weh
tun
die arme vielleicht oder würde keine
ahnung das sind das herz und da wird ja
auch genau den perfekten texturen
linksseitige schmerzen nicht mehr
das ist mein buch lieben ich kann einmal
ganz kurz das vorlesen oder ist eine
lektüre sowie bäumen heraus direkt
erstes wort falsch und meine lacher die
so schrecklich an dann heraus dass eure
schatten rege wipfel des alten heiligen
dicht belaubten heimes wie in der
gewünschten das heiligtum trete ich
jetzt noch mit schaudern dem gefühl als
wenn ich sie zum ersten mal betreten und
es gewöhnt sich nicht mein geist hierher
so manches jahr bewarb mich ihr
verborgen ein hoher wille dem ich mich
ergeben
doch immer bin ich im ersten fremd denn
8 mg trend dass mehr von den geliebten
und an dem ufer stehe ich lange tage das
land der griechen mit der seele suchend
ok also war dann müssen wir dann bei km
lang waren die paparazzi dass sie mit
haien und so sind bald gemeint und sie
ist im wald und hatte teil fernsehen
heimweh hat fernsehen total heimweh nach
griechenland weil sie wurde damals
geopfert von ihrem vater damit der
wind also das ist ein komplett komplexe
wettergeschichte das sf linie und die
ist auf tauris gefangen gehalten von
einem herrscher auf tauris namen stores
und dort muss sie als priesterin der
geniale dienen und sie hat ein reines
gewissen weil sie halt priesterin ist
und will halt immer das richtige tun
doch eines tages kommen halt ihr bruder
und ein freund von ihrem bruder die
heißen orest und kühler dass die holen
sie ab und wollen damit ihr fliehen und
dafür musik thomas wiederum anlügen und
das kann sich nicht machen das mit ihrem
gewissen nicht vereinbaren
das kann ich mit meinem gewissen
vereinbaren
ja gut und dann kommt irgendwann weg und
man muss halt alles möglich da rein
interpretieren und dann ab 12 seit ich
schaue mir jetzt mal meine lektüre ja
mach das mal erzählt mal weit aber was
passiert mit taste gedanke erfolge über
man hört richtig dass wir am ende vom
sein zimmer steht lena lauter lauter
schrei so ich habe jetzt hier 36 wollen
fehlt mir dran bist du die ganze tier so
beschäftigt ich bin die ganze zeit nur
um holz fällen
wenn ich mich hört kommt zum mikro alter
ich mache das alles über zwei etagen das
könnte ich einfach so fahren und wo er
den an der dena er wieder da wo er ua
als nämlich überhaupt gehört hat eben
jene ja auch etwas mit abgründe
ja aber er hat könnte es nur halbwissen
irgendwas ein halbwissen mit um sich
werfen
ich hab alles und das gehört ich hab mal
dass und das gehör doors kann auch
sollen ich hab mal in einer
dokumentation gesehen dass das sonntags
alles aber ich habe
ich habe jetzt mehr kafka geholt
kaiserliche botschaft der kaiser hat den
jämmerlichen untertan denen es sogar in
sein königreich geholt und an seinem
sterbebett eine botschaft gesendet den
boden hat er beim bett niederknien
lassen und bush ins ohr geflüstert so
sehr was ihm daran gelegen dass er sich
noch nie ins ohr wieder sagen ließ durch
kopfnicken hat er die richtigkeit des
gesagten stetig und vor der ganzen
zuschauerschaft seines todes alle
innenwände werden nieder gebrochen und
auf dem weit und hoch zu schwingen
freitreppen stehen im ring die großen
des reiches von all diesen hat er den
bogen abgefertigt also blablabla vor
allem die zugucken allen so allen ligen
und so alles mögliche hat er diese neben
diesen jämmerlichen boten sich gerollt
warum weiß man noch nicht der bote hat
sich gleich auf den weg gemacht ein
kräftiger ein unermüdlicher man einmal
diesen einmal den anderen arm vor
schrecken
schafft er sich bahn durch die menge
also alle schauen so weil der könig tote
soll sodann muss irgendwie durch die
menge durch
naja weil die menge ist so groß die
menge ist so groß die wohnstätte nehmen
kein ende
er kommt nicht durch einfach allgemein
die höfe waren so groß die hilfe wurden
immer größer
er findet es äußerste tor nicht entfernt
sich immer weiter
niemand bringt niemand dringend
hierdurch und gar und schon gar nicht
die botschaft eines toten also die
burgstadt des königs und der letzte satz
hat unser lehrer so kräftig angekündigt
der letzte satz du aber sitzt an einem
fenster und er träumt sie die wände
abend kommt der letzte satz hat
irgendwie gar kein zusammenhang damit
aber der letzte satz sich irgendwie auf
die zuhörer so angewendet so ja lieber
zuhörer ja eher du sitzt am fenster und
willst die botschaft wissen so will ich
das jetzt interpretieren ist dass der
zuhörer jetzt hier die botschaft wissen
will aber die botschaft nicht er kommt
und sitzt am fenster und der träume ist
dass du irgendwie weiß was so wichtig an
der botschaft war aber es sind fünf zeit
eben drin oder 6 doch voll und so das
ist so zeigt was du nie wieder in einem
ganzen leben brauchen wir jetzt genau so
wie manche wofür braucht man problem
division
also werden bieten leute die das
brauchen die prämien um die vision oder
der kaum noch härtere sachen also
polymun division ist gar nicht mehr nach
was ihr was jetzt habe das kann ich
leider nicht mehr aber dass die leute
die sowas wirklich später brauchen die
lernst dann selber können sie an der uni
lernen oder so und lernen arbeitet jetzt
alle nicht brauchen sie sollten ihre
zeit lieber mit mit wichtigeren dingen
mit mit zb oder zocken oder
gesellschaftskunde und sachen irgendwie
sowas wie zum beispiel nur vier stunden
in der woche
er ehrt können nur zwei stunden also
erst wissen wie gesagt aber es könnte
viel besser sein geschichte auch nur
zwei stunden aber dafür matte vier
stunden warum jammerte fünf stunden
mathe das grundwissen was wir jetzt
haben drei hoffen wir das reicht das
reicht einfach das reicht nur in mein
vater versteht teilweise sachen nicht
ich hier habt ihr kann man zwar so gut
sagen dass das nicht einlassen so machen
und wie macht und wie macht man das
das ist kompletter ich bin ich bin der
meinung keine ahnung wie schreibt man
seinen steuer zeug oder sowas später das
vielleicht mal ganz interessant finden
jetzt interessant da kann man mehr
gebrauchen
wie schreibe ich bei dem einen
steuererklärung und sowas keine aber
jetzt auch nicht so darauf hinaus
dürften dass man nur noch wirklich lernt
was man wirklich jetzt exakt genau das
ein nur noch das braucht dass man nur
noch das lernt was man wirklich genau
braucht nur mal so ne kurze nacht das
thema war was unser lieblingsessen wie
komplett hierhin endlich also irgendwie
weiß nicht es ist einer von euch bücher
oder so keine ahnung wer drauf gekommen
sind aber ein gutes thema vernehmen fand
ich könnte ja mal in die kommentare
schreiben gutes thema so der sohn
nicht so diese bücher ja stimmt nicht
hält an banker bin als amtlich dass eine
kommunale schreiben bücher ich was ich
essen diese bücher ich hasse ihn nicht
ab naja der neuen folge 20 okay nur nach
zwei minuten und ein neues thema ich bin
übrigens recht produktiv diese folge ich
erkenne auch ex nicht wieder
ich weiß nicht warum es in anwesenheit
von minecraft ich bin ich bin so
beruhigend
deswegen kann zu arbeiten ich wollte
würde ich auf jeden fall
wir müssen auch darauf achten was war
denn die ersten vier folgen darum
gelaufen und hat sich sachen aber bei
smart hat so wenig geredet weil wir die
ganze zeit ist uns irgendwas packard hat
gebaut gebaut gebaut oder in einer folge
wo ich am fenster stand und ich dir zu
gefunden hab und gut auf und spielt aber
nur daneben bauen sind dass wir gleich
hinein
jaja oder blieb wir vermehren hier die
schafe oder versuchen hier ein zu locken
da reiht und spart jedes mal über was
redet ihr gerade papageien war
einstecken da rein
aber wir versuchen es drauf sich auch zu
wort kommen zu lassen außer diesen
minecraft paket verschicken
ich habe ihn nicht eingeladen war
einfach da einfach da einfach da draußen
nichts bin ich gekommen eine wirkliche
termine captains bargeld verwechselt das
ich hab den zwölf als spinnen in mainz
konnte er sich selber so genannten apps
genannt und daneben
dann kam her ich bin kaputt ich finde
voll cool ich will auch folge einer
chance mottoshow soko ost abonniert ist
minecraft ich weiß ja nicht wie
rockstars mit sicherheit box clubs
kassel die größten let's play behauptet
weil sich zwei millionen irgendwas auf
twitter com
kinder sind aber keine maschine maschine
optimiert mit als jux kasse haben 35
milliarden
als patient also auch noch ein thema das
ich jemals geschrieben hatte effizient
ist voll cool
wir hatten ja in irgendeiner folge
länder geschrieben nicht geschrieben
darüber geredet und ich hatte zum
beispiel gesagt dass ich die nicht nicht
abonnieren kann weil so viel hochladen
das sollte nicht heißen dass ich scheiße
sind nur kann ich finde die allgemein
nicht witzig aber sind halt auch was ich
jetzt nicht so toll finde ist dass
teilweise echt zu fünf minuten einfach
sprechpausen das habe ich letztens
erlebt bei den part von denen die ich
will mal wieder angeguckt habe und ich
würde eigentlich eine abonnieren ich
total witzig finde aber ich habe keinen
zweck nur minecraft von den kopf dass
ich dann noch zehn andere spieler
notebooks ab und das ganze andere
untergeht und ich muss auch sagen
minecraft ist richtig witzig daisy habe
ich nie richtig geguckt aber dann kommt
zwischendurch mal so einzelprojekte von
leuten die ihm eigentlich so gar nicht
kennt so sepp also entschuldigt michael
halte ich ja ich esse ich bin ja ich
gucke jetzt nicht so viel aber das sind
also leute die da als nicht so im
vordergrund steht oder wie hd oder so
hardy hat mittlerweile mehr facebook
likes als pete das ist richtig krass
hinterher auch extrem geil einfach nur
weil er hat einfach geil aber die
direkte die sind dann auch gar nicht
besonders gut
und die werden dann auch richtig wenig
geguckt heute hat der wirt leute habt
ihr abonniert das wirklich der debitor
war auch krass dass er 130 tausend
abonnenten hat minecraft hat bei ihnen
so über 20.000 aufruf aber andere
spieler so 4000 oder aufrufe und dann
sieht man richtig weil er damals hat
wirklich so mit minecraft angefangen hat
die meisten damit wirklich wegen
minecraft abonniert